au coeur de damas la visite de dominique
de villepin dans la mosquée des
omeyyades geste symbolique en direction
de l'islam
au moment où dans l'irak voisin temps de
musulmans sont en proie aux souffrances
et au chaos de la guerre des réfugiés
irakiens ne peut être prise en photo
avec le français qui est contre la
guerre une syrienne qui les accompagnent
interpelle le ministre dans le monde
entier dit elle les arabes ne se
rendront pas partout dans le monde
partout vous alliez on est les
américains à s'écrie-t-elle le chef de
la diplomatie la ramènera la raison la
paix nous la construirons tous ensemble
y aura-t-il on doit travailler tous
ensemble
même appel à la modération aux
dirigeants syriens le président bachar
el-assad et chef de la diplomatie
syrienne farouk al shara sont
extrêmement inquiets des menaces
américaines à leur encontre
washington accuse damas d'avoir
accueilli des dignitaires du régime de
saddam hussein nous sommes victimes des
américains dira farouk al chara le
minier syrien des affaires étrangères
parce qu'ils ont échoué alors ils
montrent du doigt un troisième pays
aujourd'hui le grand défi de la
communauté internationale c'est la paix
de la même façon qu'on ne peut pas
séparer les douleurs on ne peut pas
diviser la paix paix en irak paix entre
israël et la palestine
voilà un véritable objectif pour
l'ensemble de la rue pour dominique de
villepin le proche et le moyen orient
sont un moment décisif de leur histoire
la syrie doit se réformer et s'ouvrir si
sa seule solution